[Music]
well a different kind of drama has
Taylor Swift fans slithering today so
could her new album be filled with more
of that blood hey guys it's Taylor are
you ready
Taylor has been teasing new music since
April and now her long-awaited album has
been revealed called reputation the 27
year old saying the first single will
come out tomorrow the same day Katy
Perry's music video for swish swish is
expected to drop swish swish oh it's so
on with these two with the big reveal
that her social media clues are in fact
a snake it seems the secret message is
enemies beware yep we're talking Katie
Kim and Kanye's so let's breakdown the
meaning behind this make it so he never
has been called a lot in the past and
she's clearly embracing it remember when
Kanye called Taylor Abbey and his song
infamous allegedly without her
permission
Kim snapchatted Taylor fired back That
moment when Kanye West secretly record
your phone call then Kim post it to the
Internet then Kim sent this thinly
veiled tweet aimed at Taylor on national
snake day yep that's actually a thing no
matter what you say it's wrong matter
what you do stuff is blamed on you so
she's done boyfriends and breakups we'll
Taylor's feuds be the inspiration for
her new songs we cannot wait I just
thought all right if they wanna play
this character cool I'll write a song
from that perspective and see how you
like it and it ended up being the
biggest song I've ever had
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh